[موسيقى]
انا لم اقل ابدا انها كانت ثوره ولكن قلت
دائما انها مسيره احتجاجات شعبيه كانت
وراءها اوضاع ومطالب شرعيه لشباب بالجهاد
الى اخره
لكن ان نقول انها ثوره يجب ان نرى من هي
قيادتها ما هو برنامجها من وراء الى اخره
ولكن تلك الاحتجاجات وخصوصا بعد خروج
الرئيس من علي
فسحت المكان لكل من كان
يترصد هو يتربص بالسلطه واخدوها
على ذلك من اطراف مختلفه
بريطانيا
لقدميه مكان على الساحه ورايين كيف ان
عشريه كامله بعد ذلك لم تكن عسيريه
التجديد الحكم بل كانت عشريه اغتساما
للغنائم
[موسيقى]
الاخوان
ذكائهم في التعدد
الجباتهم
الاوروبيه المصريه
يمكن ان اقول رماهم لكن دون ان ان يكون في
الكلمه يعني معنى سلبي لانه رمتهم افعالهم
عندما يفتح المجال الاتجاه الاسلامي سابقا
الذي اصبح
منذ سبعينات قام باعمال مشاغبه واعمال
العنف سنه 77 في الفنادق السياحيه في
الساحل سنه 81
تحركات تلماذيه في الشوارع وحاول ان ان
يستغل شباب صغار يعني شباب المدارس
[موسيقى]